before the break we listed four factoids
about carrie underwood and i have to
guess
which one is true loves to eat frog's
legs
listens to asmr before bed has a fear of
turtles has a pet snake
i'm gonna go with c has a fear of
turtles you are correct
that's so cool that i guessed right
there was something about it that kind
of left out as unique
yes i mean it's uh it's not a
like you know petrifying fear
um of turtles i i feel like out of all
the animals on the planet
they're the ones who have bit me the
most
very strange i grew up in the country um
turtles were the easiest things to catch
because they are slow
and i i would catch them and i
love animals so much um that i feel like
i would always try to
pet them or hug them and that led to
them taking opportunities i've been
bitten by
lots of turtles it does not feel good um
i am obsessed with your book
find your path it's so beautifully put
together
as is your app this really spoke to me
because like in the organizational
tips i just like to discuss sort of how
to
um you know kind of real talk like we
all have aspirations but we can all find
a million excuses
or we can have things sort of stymie our
way in direction
i love this card thing you have with
your trainer
which is what led to the name of um
52 yeah well it i feel like everything
in the book is it's just all about being
approachable and real
at the core of what i do i'm a working
mom of a busy schedule
taking kids to school and to whatever
practices are going on
and just juggling like we all are
and you know we offer a lot of a lot of
hacks and tricks to eating healthy on
the go and just making sure you have
some easily grabbable foods in your
refrigerator and in your pantry that
you can find anywhere enjoy your life it
is all about balance
um we do talk about the fit 52
workout my trainer eve overland and i um
kind of fine tuned it's a game that's
been around for a while but we we use a
deck of cards and
you flip a card over and the the suit
tells you what exercise you're doing
whatever you've laid out for yourself
and the number tells you how many reps
so it's like you keep flipping you keep
flipping sometimes you get the ace which
is 14
and you're like uh it's the ace but then
it's over with uh when you're done and
then the next time you'll draw two
and it's only two so it keeps things
moving
and it's kind of circuit training at its
uh
basic basic uh level um but it's fun and
it keeps things
keeps things rolling i think there is
such a poetry
and a joy i want to go home tonight
and whip out my deck of cards and do
this
i also will be downloading your
playlist suggestions which i skim
through and completely speak to me
and boy doesn't music change everything
it does i mean that's such a great tip
to to getting into the gym as well make
it fun
you know play your games switch it up
have a playlist
you know if you're feeling and and my
playlists vary from day to day sometimes
i just want this morning i did something
it was like all about boy bands
and like the whole thing was just boy
bands and i was like this is
this is fun it's just keeping it fun
because you wonder who's gonna come next
and
um yeah it's it's just fun to to switch
it up and
get silly it's okay well i
think that you really did accomplish
your intention which is making it
inviting
i want in on this party and i know
you're doing a collaboration with body
armor light
why did this partnership make sense to
you i mean all the things that we just
talked
about things being real and a part of my
life
and and wanting um all of it to go
together so i've i've been a fan of of
body armor and
their sports water and body armor light
and uh
it just worked in my life so like other
things that i've
been able to be a part of and work with
um
if they're in my life i want to talk
about them if i like things i want to
talk about them i want to be a part of
it
um what is your favorite flavor i have
some here i
i like the coconut i like the berry
punch i like the
orange clementine um it's hard to pick a
favorite
they're they're really all all good i'm
gonna go
coconut because i am coconut
for coconuts harry
this is so good and i'm not kidding good
and that all the stuff in it is really
good i
i really love your world and i i
appreciate that you're sharing it with
everybody because then it does invite us
in
so thank you for that thank you
you